don't have a bunch of crap in a blender
and blend it wait it's blended - I
haven't never had a Frappuccino not once
I have never had a Frappuccino which I
know a lot of people think is weird but
I don't drink coffee
I've never had any type of coffee a
super black coffee in my entire life I
have never had a Frappuccino nor have I
ever had any coffee flavored anything or
I guess coffee itself it's never
appealed to me ever see them doing the
pumps when I go in there I was like I
got just get like a small black coffee
I'm trying something for the first time
that everyone else has had so yeah I'm a
little nervous I don't even know it's in
a Frappuccino
actually I just lift up on Wikipedia
Thank You cheeky nose I assume it's just
a milkshake with yeah does it make you
poop like regular coffee does or is it
Mitsy poop yeah coffee does I just
here's the floodgates open up why have I
not experienced something that really
was like all of America fraud never
having one I'm just like well now we're
gonna ruin it Jones but were there
different flavors an urn had like cold
coffee before what
leading the [ __ ] slow like you go after
I go right it's got a strong coffee
aftertaste that I'm not into but like
the initial taste was kind of like a
chocolaty a tree it's pretty sweet I
feel like the first is like a Pepsi that
initial sinner just like you know what
this is not bad and then
it just kind of coat your tongue and
you're like all right I don't want to
stop now it's still sitting with me I
know you can't really taste the coffee
which I'm not disappointed about I feel
like this is like a good thing for kids
to get into coffee with oh my god it's
green it looks like it would be healthy
because it's green I honestly didn't
know that you could get a Frappuccino
with that coffee so right now my mind's
blown that was a big sale it's like a
green tea Kit Kat it's not bad I don't
know I kind of taste a little minty
that's very tasting pretty good I should
I could tell you I guess I'll do you
another one delicious it's like a green
tea milkshake can I finish this though
this one what's dangerous
I feel like now this is a drink off the
pill and you look at form perfect this
feels like straight sugar to me but I
love it actually this is not that bad do
you like it I really do cherry
strawberry flavor that's very like thick
and that cream just like hits you like a
train it's like strawberry milk with a
bunch of sugar in it I guess
and I always liked strawberry milk as a
kid it tastes like those old like Nestle
Quik milkshakes strawberry Nestle Quik
it's probably down this and like three
sips if I wanted to
after going my whole life without ever
having a Frappuccino and then now having
one yeah the mystery is is gone the veil
has been lifted I've seen the wizard I
had no idea frappuccinos were cold but
maybe in the future I have a sip of one
of my friends forever Geno's I'm gonna
stick with black coffee
I feel feel frappe doubt I was like
having a bad day I would order and just
be like [ __ ] it I need this I don't know
I'm gonna be able to join the
Frappuccino call and like blend in and I
don't have to drink coffee
Chelsea look that I got
this is a weird straw
[Music]